what's going on guys this is rob and we
are covering the single greatest kang
story of all time uh the one that
recently completed which is basically
retold the origin of kang which is
called only myself left to conquer the
reason why i say it's a retelling or a
reworking of his origin is because
kang's origin does exist in marvel
comics the problem is it's scattered all
over the damn place so you've got marvel
two in one comics you've got some marvel
premiere comics you've got some journey
into mystery you've got fantastic four
some avengers stuff but you have all
kinds of comics that all just sort of
feed into this great big huge origin of
king what this does is it consolidates
all the stuff that marvel wants to keep
it changes the things they don't and
tells us how kane the conqueror became
king to conquer here's the problem this
story relies on you understanding
rahmatut and immortus and iron lad and
all that stuff so um we have to explain
that before we get into this now we do
have a full-on explanation about kang
but even then people said it was still a
bit confusing so we're going to replace
kang with you and you are going to
imagine you are king and we're going to
explain it that way and if this can't
solve it i don't know what can so here's
the thing
imagine you right now living your life
watching this video and imagine that you
suddenly discovered the ability to
travel back in time right and you can do
anything you want to well i mean you're
you're like hey i'm going to go back in
time and conquer everything that's what
i'm going to do i'm going to go back to
the days of ancient egypt i'm going to
change my name and i'm going to conquer
all of existence so you go all the way
back to the days of ancient egypt and
you start calling yourself ramatuch and
because of your technological
advancement you're literally taking
technology as it exists right now back
then let me tell you something you show
up there with an ink pen you're gonna
blow the minds of the people in ancient
egypt right they're they're they're
gonna free they're gonna think you're
god right like they're they're not gonna
know how to process that information let
alone if you took back something like a
computer which you couldn't use or a
notepad or something along those lines
right just technology that they hadn't
even considered yet so you go back in
time you change your name to rama tut
you rule that for for a particular
period of time now somebody here in the
present day doesn't matter who it is
realizes what you're doing they go back
in time and they basically chase you out
of ancient egypt right they're like you
don't need to be here uh you're a bad
guy in the confines of the comics it's
the fantastic four let's say whoever
this person is they basically fight you
they overpower you and you're forced to
flee otherwise you're going to die so
your intention is to say okay fine look
i have the ability to time travel i can
go anywhere i want to i mean i'm not
just going to quit after being beat once
right it's like the dating game right
try try again
and so you're like okay i'm going to go
back to 2022 and i'm going to concoct a
new plan on how to conquer the past but
along along the way back along your
journey back here suddenly you end up in
limbo and you're just like okay what is
this place right and you explore the
whole area you start looking around you
come across technology different things
like that now while you're here in limbo
it allows you to look at the entire time
stream past present future the distant
future so you could literally watch your
life unfold from the realm of limbo and
what you do is you come to this
realization you're inevitably going to
become a villain that's a problem not
only are you going to become a villain
now there's an infinite number of
universes out there where you took
different paths and did different things
and caused different problems and maybe
you form a whole council of yourself
right like literally hundreds of you who
all meet together occasionally and do
some crazy stuff and so what this does
is it leads to to you as you exist in
limbo saying okay i don't want to become
my villainous self i don't want to
become that villain version of me so i'm
going to stay here and i'm going to do
everything i can to work against myself
here's the problem what you have here is
a situation where you will inevitably
have to end up going back and becoming
that villainous version of yourself
because you exist right it's a paradox
that villainous version of yourself went
back into the past and became rama tut
which led you on your journey to where
you are right now calling yourself
immortus which means you know that's
inevitably going to happen no matter
what you do that's the future that's
guaranteed for you so what you're doing
is trying to work to keep that from
happening now let's move away from that
version of yourself right you're just
kind of out there doing your thing now
let's say that this future version of
yourself in the 31st century as you're
there you come to this realization
people are going to work against me and
it's entirely possible that even even me
even even i myself may not become this
version of myself that's entirely
possible i may not i may lose the
ability to time travel or may never gain
the ability to time travel maybe i
decide to go to burger king instead of
mcdonald's and that shifts up everything
right so now i don't have the ability to
time travel any number of things could
happen that could that could prevent
that so what i need to do is i need to
go into the past and i need to meet with
my younger self and i need to make sure
that my younger self does all the things
that they're supposed to do so that i
can exist and so you do that you go back
and you meet with your younger self and
you basically tell your younger self
look i'm the guy you're gonna become and
so here's what you gotta do right you
gotta you gotta do this thing you gotta
do all these different things over the
course of time and if you don't you're
never gonna become me well your younger
self looks at you and says well i don't
want to be you i have no desire to
become you right you're a dick like i
don't want to be you at all so i'm going
to do everything i possibly can not to
become you and so as a result you've
made an enemy out of your younger self
now for our explanation here with kane
the conqueror when you went back in time
and became a ruler of egypt that's rama
tut that's kane the conqueror becoming
ramatun when you ended up going to limbo
and started calling yourself immortus
that was king the conqueror and in the
future when you go into the past and
meet with your younger self to try to
get your younger self to ensure they
become you that's iron lad that's how
all those things work together having
said that i don't know how else to
explain it besides that if that can't
explain kane the conqueror for you
nothing can
either that or i'm just that bad at it
having said all that spent the last six
minutes explaining that let's get into
the comic the reason why you guys are
here if i haven't lost half of you
already so here's the thing what this
does is it initially picks up with
nathaniel richards in the 31st century
and what he says here is he says life at
this point in time really just kind of
sucks it's very very drab and very very
boring he says by the time he'd reached
the age of 18 he had conquered nothing
that his world was a utopia of pleasure
and entertainment that is so-called
bettors called it post-scarcity he
called it born a utopia to be sure where
ten-year-olds could master advanced
robotics where a boy could have his
throat cut by bullies and recover in a
matter of months which is actually what
happened to him but it was also a place
where time seemed to stop that it was
the end of history a meaningless
procession of tepid moments a countdown
to nothing that while this utopia is
beneficial for society as a whole in the
sense that nobody wants for anything
there is truth to the statement conflict
is in one way what gives people purpose
but is also what drives them to become
better that if people reach a point
where there is no conflict where there's
no struggling or no suffering or no pain
nobody will have a reason to improve
themselves because everybody will have
everything that they want and in the
face of that what you would likely run
into is a situation of stagnation now
whether that would happen in the real
world or not i have no idea but it's
what happened to silver surfers planet
is what happened to the people of zen
law they stopped focusing on religion
started focusing on science they
explored everything there was to explore
in the universe they cured every illness
that could possibly plague their people
they understood everything perfectly and
suddenly there was no more reason to
live because they had it all figured out
they had the answer to everything the
purpose behind life simply ceased to
exist and so what you end up getting is
basically nathaniel who goes on this
kind of personal quest where he
literally just starts traveling to these
old places that have long since been
forgotten and in a lot of ways we're
kind of off limits to the average person
but what he longed for was adventure
what he longed for was the this kind of
bygone age you know an era that he was
nostalgic for despite the fact that he
never lived in it he was kind of looking
to this time when there were straight-up
heroes and they were straight-up
villains all that kind of stuff
fantastic four doctor doom the avengers
whoever in the hell else they happen to
be fighting all kinds of things and so
what he ends up doing and going to this
museum he actually ends up stumbling
across a doombot and that's kind of the
crazy thing is because remember doctor
doom by this point is long since dead
and it's kind of a crazy thing because
one of the big questions people have
when it comes to nathaniel richards is
who is he related to because marvel's
played it both ways they've said that
nathaniel richards is descended from
victor von doom but they've also said
nathaniel richards is is descended from
reed richards well maybe not necessarily
said that but it's kind of been
sort of alluded to over the years and so
that's kind of a funny thing because
contextually we kind of get an answer
here that when this doombot activates
because it's just one of the creations
of viktor von doom designed to stand the
test of time when it activates and
starts attacking him then of course this
leads to king the conqueror showing up
king as we know him showing up here
destroying the doombot and then of
course the kid saying like who in the
world are you right like you need to
answer me i am descended from and then
of course the whole thing gets cut off
now that's where contextually we could
argue that he is descended from victor
von doom the problem here is that if he
was it's very likely the doombot would
have obeyed him when he told the doombot
to stop so again it's one of those
things where we kind of get an answer
and we kind of don't marvel's never
really solidified it and to be honest
with you guys i don't think they ever
will i don't think marvel will ever give
us a definitive answer as to whether or
not kang is the the you know progeny or
the descendant of reed or victor i don't
think we'll ever get an answer but it's
kind of a cool thing there is because
ultimately where the two of them have
this kind of conversation kane the
conqueror approaches this from saying
like your voice is embarrassing right
like there is no easier place to lie
than in the pages of a book you'll learn
to trust only first-hand sources though
i suppose compared to the gruel that's
been that you've been raised on in this
place this would appear to be a feast so
let me ask you would you rather read
history or would you rather make history
and so the allure of this adventure the
allure of being able to actually go and
live these adventures that he'd spent so
much time reading about that's what
draws the interest of nathaniel richards
and so at the end you know of course in
this conversation nathaniel's like are
you kidding me right like that's the
only thing i want this world is so thin
it's like there's absolutely nothing
here and i want everything and so the
response of kang is good that means
you're ready so now ask your question
again but ask it with conviction and the
kid says who are you and this guy you
know king responds and says it's i've
been called a thousand things right ten
thousand different names by all these
different worlds that i've conquered and
so on and so forth like i've been called
a conqueror i've been called the eternal
the god pharaoh rahmatut the timekeeper
immortus but despite all of them there's
only one name that truly rings true and
that's king the conqueror and so he says
in the beginning before all of it i was
you and so it's an amazing conversation
that happens here because he says
through this doorway is an infinite
number of times and worlds eras that
sing my name and praise planets that
worship me but to earn those i have
known loss defeat and frustration he
says i would save you that trauma and
all of that time join me and own the
mysteries of the cosmos join me and
become king the conqueror and so in the
end it doesn't take a whole lot to
convince nathaniel the world he's in is
so boring and it's so basic and it's so
simple that in the end he's like
absolutely right so he immediately joins
him on this quest and what happens the
first stop is king takes him to 65
million years before common era the age
of the dinosaur specifically one year
before the asteroid hits that wipes out
all the dinosaurs on earth and what king
says is like this is your first lesson
right time means nothing to kink like
yes i'm dropping you off here and yes
you have a year to become you but you
think that way because you're thinking
two-dimensionally in a three-dimensional
world right like it's it's a it's an an
interesting concept right like people
trying to make it in the real world how
do i succeed become successful and
wealthy in the real world i know by
working for someone else and that's not
true it's thinking two-dimensionally in
a three-dimensional world you have to
think outside the box what can you do on
your own that can make you better absent
the influence and the need of other
individuals out there can you build a
world for yourself or are you satisfied
in living in someone else's and so
that's the cool thing here is because
what kang says and this is one of the
most important things that he says it's
easy to overlook it's easy to not take
seriously but one of the things he says
is he says many of my memories are
fogged by the ways of time centuries of
conflicting timelines playing tricks in
my head but i remember every one of
those first days with clarity my lessons
began with survival strengthening my
body and mind where i could not
strengthen it myself kang did so for me
now the reason why this matters and this
kind of goes back to our initial
explanation of why it was so necessary
involving immortus and and rahmatut and
all those different guys is because
whenever kang went back in time and
fashioned a life for himself he became
that person he became that person that
he was pretending to be and so here's
what i want you to do right in order to
truly understand how this impacts kang
here's what i want you to do i want you
to put in the comments or at least tell
me what did you have for dinner on
january 26
2019 you can't tell me and if you did
tell me i would probably just think you
were lying just making something up in
order to be like yep i remember
everything no no nobody remembers that
that singular moment there right now
that's a couple years ago and if i if i
change that question and said would you
have for dinner on monday last week
you'd be able to give me a much better
guess but instead of this being two
years ago let's pretend it's 10 000
years ago and a life that you lived for
90 years that's what kane contends with
that's the issue that he has and that's
why oftentimes in comics you'll see kang
come across immortus or iron lad or
something like that and it'll almost be
like they're completely different people
because by all standards of measurement
they basically are right like imagine
you went back in time 50 years and lived
out an entire life and then at the end
of that life came back to the modern age
and then just lived for another thousand
years here after a while you wouldn't
really even remember what that what that
lifetime was like when you went back 50
years ago but it does exist and that
version of yourself is there so it's
just one of those those weird and
interesting things about kang it's why
you do have different variations of
himself but they're also starkly
different in the end though this cycle
always continues right it's like
battlestar galactica all of this has
happened before and all of this will
happen again that kang always becomes
king and king always goes and finds his
younger self and always leads his
younger self to become ken the exception
is iron lad but at the end of the day
the argument still stands that iron lad
will inevitably become king the
conqueror so it's one of these things
where he talks about when whenever he
says king showed me this just imagine
this cycle as it happens right now
except this young nathaniel richards
grows up to be this adult king and this
adult king is basically reliving or
retelling his experiences as you see
them here he's basically recalling the
life that we're gonna see this young
nathaniel richards live over the course
of this comic it's very meta textual but
that's why it's so loopy that's why it
goes in circles and cycles and so that's
why as as young nathaniel is talking
about all this he says king showed me
our life as a pharaoh of egypt and
taught me its lesson and he laid bare
the rules of time which lit my mind
ablaze he says his lessons were brutal
and he says i was proud when i overcame
them as i was proud of what we would
build together he taught me to shoot he
taught me to kill he taught me that a
plan no matter how meticulous only
serves to make you weak he forged me
just as he promised but as i was forged
so did i glimpse the flaws in the iron
that made my teacher now this is an
important thing because one of the
things that you usually see when it
comes to kane and conqueror is him
showing up on the scene doing some stuff
all kinds of hell unleashing conflict
unfolding and that's basically it you
never really get to see the
interpersonal side of ken the part of
kang that struggles because one of the
things he says is he says that once king
got so drunk that he could barely stand
and he took me to a far-off world where
he cried in the shadows as a woman died
he said one word then was silent for
days that word being ravana right of
course ravana rensslayer now the thing
of the thing about this the reason why
it matters is because ravana ren slayer
was the love interest of kane the
conqueror and she died right king's life
literally fell apart when that happened
in fact the way that marvel wrote that
it was almost kind of a question of will
king ever recover from this it was
focusing on that interpersonal side but
you don't really see it all that often
and of course even kang made nathaniel
swear he would never bring it up right
like he would never mention it or
anything along those lines and so what
happens as he goes through this period
right again back in the 65 million years
that he's here as he goes through all of
that of course he ends up facing off
against you know some tyrannosaurus rex
which is awesome blasts it with some
with a massive gun
that literally blows this thing's head
off and what he says is this is where
things are really really fascinating and
he says he would love to say that in the
aftermath of killing this t-rex that he
feasted on dinosaur meat for days and he
sharpened its teeth into knives right
that he somehow honed his skills became
this brutal warrior that could live off
the land but he says that never happened
and the reason why is because by the
time i killed this thing all i saw was
her all i saw was this one person right
this one singular individual and like
that she had the complete and total
attention of kang he never had a chance
right nathaniel was just smitten for
this woman and what was more interesting
than this is that in the society that he
came from physical touch didn't happen
you never physically touched people it
was always done as a kind of synthesis
right a kind of uh you know barrier
between you and somebody else is a way
to like prevent disease illness
different things like that and so for
the first real time in his life he's
experiencing tactile contact with
another human being more so than that
he's experiencing love he's experiencing
desire he's having all these feelings
that he's never quite really been
through before and so having this kind
of experience with her in a lot of ways
i wouldn't go as far as to say she's in
love with him and i would even go as far
as to say he's not necessarily in love
with her if anything it's more passing
curiosity now that will change that will
inevitably change but of course she kind
of invites him to her tribe and so of
course he ends up basically chasing her
down following her to that location and
he's taken before the people here now
what's kind of baffling is that from
nathaniel richards perspective there
shouldn't be any human beings here now i
use that based on the real world right
that like uh primitive human beings
appeared maybe something around 300 000
years ago that the anatomical version of
ourselves that exists now it's probably
about 200 000 years ago and then over
time our minds just progressed to where
we are right now uh in marvel comics one
thing to know is that when it comes to
the evolution of the human race we're
not really given anything before the
arrival of the celestials like even at
mobile comics it'll do that the closest
that we ever really got in terms of
those early days is maybe a little bit
of discussion about proto-mutants uh
with gabriel shepard the old stories
with uh not really old story i guess
they are now jesus i'm old 20 something
year old stories 21 year old stories by
grant morrison
with new x-men
jesus lime mold
christ
in any event um we're not really given
an actual origin point for when modern
man first appeared in marvel comics so i
could almost guarantee though it wasn't
65 million years ago
and this race as is being told right
this girl addie and her race we're not
really given any information so we don't
really know if like their time displaced
or anything like that they certainly
don't act like it but nathaniel is
brought before the lasting peace which
is basically their elder right the the
leader of the tribe who kind of gives us
this perception that he knows who
nathaniel richards is going to become
but he doesn't know he's going to become
king if anything it's more of his
actions that demonstrate who he is as a
person the fact that he saved addy's
life from a dinosaur the fact that he
killed the dinosaur basically shows that
he is a person of conviction and
strength and as a result he's brought
into the tribe and honored as a warrior
by basically being given face paint now
the other part of this is that the tribe
again because they're primitive relies
on you know prophecies from the stars
and different things like that so
they're very much given to superstition
right this kind of a thing and of course
according to the prophecies handed down
from the elders you know presumably the
ones that came before the last in peace
and by the lasting peace himself they're
doomed to be destroyed by a star right
by like literally a meteor crashing into
earth they don't really know that's what
it is but that's basically what it is
and so the thing about this is that
nathaniel flees to kane the conqueror
and says we have the ability to
manipulate time neal time does not
matter to us so let's just take them
somewhere else let's take them to a
future right we can just snatch them up
while they're sleeping or whatever it is
but we can take them to you know some
period when the earth is habitable again
and then go from there now this is one
of the most important things that goes
on with this new origin of king to
conquer cain the conqueror's concern is
not a disruption of the time streak the
reality is that it would right most
likely the destruction of this race
serves some purpose along the timeline
right their bones are discovered or
something like that somebody makes some
kind of a discovery which leads them
down some path where they do some things
and then that leads to them becoming a
superhero and changes the entire course
of stuff who knows but regardless like
you can't necessarily meddle with the
time stream in that way and so what
happens here is that when nathaniel runs
to king and asks like are you awake the
response of kang is that no it is you
who's not awake right you're you dream
the naive dreams of heroes the romance
of alexander the purity of steve rogers
you will unlearn this sentimentality
never disappear from my sight again you
will do as you are ordered you will
learn the lessons i teach and never
disregard them and above all else you
will wipe that pathetic paint off of
your face and the response of nathaniel
is no that's not going to happen and so
as an answer to this kang simply says i
do not make requests right you are here
by my design and shall behave by my
design your future lies in the balance
heed me or be doomed to a life of
failure of rot and toil and
insignificance and that's when
nathaniel's like but that's the point
you're the one who's failed you talk
endlessly about conquest and glory but
you're just a drunk who makes me
memorize his defeats how doom tricked
you at the fall of manhattan how the
fantastic four laid you low in the sands
of egypt and so this is kind of back and
forth argument and in the end nathaniel
says my life is my own it's out there
living on without me and the people of
that tribe we can save them from the
coming cataclysm if time means nothing
to us then why can't i use it to save
the first and last in this blasted world
and in the end the response of kang is
you believe that because you're in love
and it's that love that makes you weak
it's that love that takes away any
measure of strength that you could have
that's the stance that king has his
sentimentality the fact that he's
experienced love and kindness and
romance he sees that as a weakness he
sees it as the thing that had always
held him back that if he could go back
in time and he could alter that younger
version of himself so that he didn't
experience love that that sentimentality
was stamped out of him then those
weaknesses would never come to fruition
in those moments when he hesitated
instead of killing the fantastic four
due to some sentimentality or some
statement made by reed or susan or
something like that right like who's
gonna take care of our children that if
that sentimentality wasn't there he
would have pulled the trigger without
hesitation that cruelty would have
dominated and so in order to try to
demonstrate this he drags nathaniel to
the camp when nathaniel says i will save
them the response of king is no boy you
did not and opens fire on the place just
incinerates kills everybody there every
single person dies right they're
completely and totally killed and
nathaniel can do nothing more than just
sit there and watch now this is hugely
important because what he says is it was
then that i understood though i had
crossed the fabric of space and time i
had never left my cage at all it was
then that i saw the cage was king and so
what he did is he basically made this
promise to himself that he wouldn't
become king he says and so for the final
months of the cretaceous i pretended to
study that which king instructed while
secretly i studied the lock how the
mention of ravana might drive my jailer
to drink how a few herbs might
intoxicate a glass of wine how the armor
that it opened the way might be mine to
command i'd rarely been as tempted as i
was in that moment to take the
inevitable into my own hands but his
words echoed in my ear time would
conquer all my enemies if only i could
master it and so literally it almost
appears on the surface this is how king
becomes iron lad but that doesn't
necessarily seem to be the case instead
as this meteor comes crashing down into
the world with the intention of
destroying it and basically leading to
the end of all things he ultimately ends
up walking away travels through a time
portal and when he does he finds himself
in the realm of rama tut and depending
on who you talk to who reads marvel
comics some will tell you that rahmatut
is far more extreme than kang ever was
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section about this honestly again i
think it's the best kane the conqueror
story that i've ever read and we still
got four more parts so we're gonna bring
this to an end guys and i will catch you
all later
peace